-Our next guest is
a talented actor
you know from shows
such as "True Blood"
and movies like
the "Magic Mike" franchise
He stars in "Archenemy,"
which is in theaters, on deman
and digital December 11th.
Let's take a look.
-So what are we supposed to do
-You stay and you fight the war.
-Hamster, don't engage
with the troll.
-Fight the war?
-[ Sucks teeth ] Oh, God.
-How we supposed to do that?
-Don't undersell yourself.
I'm here with you.
I fell through a black hol
to get here.
And I never knew why until now
It was so I could help you
Both of you.
-Please welcome back
to the show Joe Manganiello.
How are you, Joe?
-I'm doing great.
How are you, Seth?
-I'm doing well.
You know, I knew
this was gonna happen.
I had you circled
on the calendar.
Our Pittsburgh Steelers
were 11-0,
and the minute I saw
they were playing last night
I was like, "Something bad
is gonna happen
so that Joe and I can't
celebrate together."
You still must feel optimistic
about the season.
-I do, yeah.
I mean, we're 11-1.
You know, our loss yesterday
dropped us to the number-one
seed in the AFC.
We're still okay.
-We're still okay.
I'm very much enjoying
this bald hairstyle.
A couple weeks ago, you were
rocking this, which is, uh..
I mean, again,
this was for a role.
And I believe what you have no
is for a role, right?
These are not choices
that you're making
based on how it looks.
-Well...
-[ Laughs ]
-I could hear, like, a littl
tinge of something in your voice
as you said that, but...
So, I had a white Mohawk
for a job,
and then I have bald head
for a job.
In between, I got to, yes,
make some life choices,
and the blue Mohawk was for me
-I'm very excited about
your white Mohawk job,
but I'm curious if your wife
Sofia Vergara --
is she happy when you have
white Mohawk jobs?
-I think she's happy with --
happiest with jobs
in which I look like I looke
when we first met.
Yeah, there's something
about that.
It was like putting water
in the cement mix --
it just creates concrete.
Like, whenever you meet, that'
the way she wants me to stay
But, you know, she knew
she was marrying an actor
and she knew it was gonna ge
weird at some point, Seth,
and it has.
-With that said,
you married an actor, too,
and she's looked the exact sam
for like 20 years.
[ Laughter ]
-That's correct.
I am not looking forward
to her white Mohawk role.
-[ Laughs ] Very fair.
This is a cool part.
You play a character
named Max Fist.
Tell us a little bit about it.
-You know, Max Fist is,
for me --
I mean, the character
I'm playing --
he's a meth-addicted alcoholic
homeless, maybe schizophrenic,
has some psychotic episodes,
you know, bum who lives
in a tent under a bridge.
So it was a whole different,
you know, movie for me.
I didn't really play
the superhero.
The thing is, is he has thes
delusions or these visions
or dreams or maybe they're
memories -- he's not sure --
where he was, like,
the champion,
a superpower champion
from another dimension,
and that's really what he
believes, who he believes he is.
And you just don't know if he is
or if he isn't.
-It's very cool, and I kno
you're someone who, like myself,
growing up, I think we liked
the idea of heroes,
we liked comic books,
and obviously, you've had
experience doing that.
In 2002, you were in
that "Spider-Man,"
and I did not realize
that you actually auditioned
to play Spider-Man,
the role that Tobey Maguir
ended up playing.
-Yeah, all the young men
who appear in the film,
we all auditioned
to play Peter Parker.
Tobey obviously auditioned
to play Peter Parker,
James Franco screen-tested
as Peter Parker,
and I originally auditione
for Peter Parker when I went in.
We all read the same sides and
then were nudged into our roles.
-Did you know
that you weren't, maybe,
like, a perfect fit
for Peter Parker?
Because this would be a case
where he would be, like,
bitten by a radioactive spider
that made him, like,
a little bit weaker?
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
I mean, you know, the trope or
the archetype of Peter Parke
is that he's this, like, nerd.
He's, you know, very smart
but not the cool guy at school
and he is in love with
the cool guy's girlfriend.
And so, I knew that, you know,
no matter how much of a nerd
I am on the inside,
I'm never going to get cas
as Peter Parker,
because, you know,
I'm 6'5", 200-whatever.
So finding the bullies for m
would be really odd.
I just didn't fit that role.
I knew that I'd fit the part
of Flash, or the bully, better
And I actually came prepared
I learned those scenes
and was off-book on them
when I got there.
And when I read to play
Peter Parker,
I had glasses on
and a button-down shirt.
And the casting director said,
"You know, that was great,
but you're never gonna get
this role."
I said, "I know, I know."
She said, "But there's thi
other part."
I said, "Flash."
She said, "Yeah."
She said, "That's probably
better for you."
I go, "Oh, great." I go...
And she goes, "Let me go
get the script."
I go, "No, no, no, I've got it
I'm off-book, let's go."
And I took off the glasses
and started unbuttoning
the button-down shirt
and I had a tank top underneat
and I went straight into
the Flash sides.
And at the end, she said,
"I want you to meet Sam Raimi.
And she got me a job
the following week
that paid me $500 to screen-test
as Flash on film
against the other
Spider-Man candidates.
One of them was James Franco
-Ah, that is incredible.
And I think a good lesson
to all actors
to be a little bit more prepared
than they even ask you to.
A nice ending for you.
And it's always great
to see you.
Thanks so much for making time
for us today, Joe.
-Thanks, man. Go Steelers.
-Go Steelers.
"Archenemy" is in theaters
on demand and digital
December 11th.